yeah two people were arrested smash and
grab robbery using sharp objects removed
property but I guess they did it before
and one of the security guards at the
mall was like oh I recognize that guy
and that's how they figured it out oh
there was one you know those rappers
they go to a special jeweler that just
happened recently a word they just did
in broad daylight they just came in fast
and took all this crap and all like the
bloody fancy chains fancy dying she's a
pink Panther's have you seen this group
I see no you're right they've gotten
away with a billion dollars every column
yet right they're incredible Dan by the
way when they caught one they've every
time they catch him they break him out
of jail they'll throw a bunch of
weaponry oh and bolt cutters over the
fence catapulted over and those
[ __ ] grabbing they're the
baddest group of and they thought they
were Special Forces guys just a bunch of
kids that grew up in a war-torn Serbian
you know each other bring up bring up
video of them doing that it there they
they study them because they're so
and I think DiCaprio is gonna do a movie
about this from under here they're so
good at at basically figuring out
lowchen dam they have a logo named after
the pink Panther's Pink Panther series
of crime Tommy feels the pink Lancers
name given by Interpol to international
jewel thief Network consists of 200 to
250 members from very amount enero
Croatia Bosnia Wow there's such badasses
and and and they're rough but they've
never killed anybody they'll they'll
[ __ ] with the you know I'll arias was in
prison now though yeah they've caught
not all of them some of them you can't
you can't get away with it for too long
but in Tokyo they got away with five
hundred million dollars whether I mean
it's crazy five hundred million it's
like dude I mean they did it in with a
bra until Robin Kardashian in in Monaco
no that was a different thing in Monaco
these [ __ ] guys came in they have
video they actually have YouTube videos
there's scroll out chin yeah there it is
annex being Panther on his little crew
blamed for robbing there you go Kim
credit oh she got wrapped robbed in a
friend oh that one I'm a man hey do some
highlight happy was high level because
they were involved with the security
with Kim Kardashian
so she got you know wrote Rob
like they're they're really gutsy but on
YouTube you see them doing she held her
at gunpoint still nine million jewelry
in the middle of Monaco in Monaco like
they break in they steal you know 100
million dollars worth of jewelry and get
on speedboats and Rider and drive away
speedboats and each heist would cost
them about a hundred thousand dollars to
get all the equipment and everything
organized and every single one of them
had to rely on each other so that's why
they were so good
four hundred members one boss
Jesus is there go to youtube they've
studied how they do it so quickly they
just will are we allowed to show that
though not really but we can check it
out look at it be any porn yeah it's
just them stealing stuff and watch the
top one yeah sure it's compilation their
ride right drive right through huh that
looks like a movie got see [ __ ]
think about how much fun this would be
to live on the edge like this you like
this [ __ ] huh I mean it's just so I did
that president get a job it's pretty
impressive when they get away with a
billion dollars worth of tools and
they're doing it more for the [ __ ]
excitement of it all with assault rifles
oh yeah they don't [ __ ] around this is
movie [ __ ] though dude yeah I mean they
made the Italian Job you know Mark
Wahlberg yeah these guys the real
Italian drops yeah I think that what is
yeah you and I should make a lot of
money and just go buy those jewels it's
much easier to just go and buy them here
you go
your credit you take credit card there's
a smart guy you think they'd figure out
a way to you make money illegal which I
think that they asked him of that I mean
a lot of them were just they grew up in
a war-torn country and saw a lot of
violence and we're like you know [ __ ] it
you know it's five hundred twenty years
eight hundred core members biggest
European art heist ever 163 million yeah
damn three hours seventy robberies in 35
countries and now that's organized but
they cut the head one huh I remember in
New York there was a group of Russians
or they didn't know who they were and
they were they were taking they would
come in they'd break in that go to an
ATM machine and sawed it in half
with these special saws like that and
then just take all the money you know
some people do some crazy [ __ ] I be in
and out in three minutes and possible to
catch em we talked about a few weeks ago
in here that they were Irish we know
they had the crane yeah Ireland duck and
just picked it up drop the ATM machine
in the car and drove off they destroyed
the whole side of that whatever that
building they didn't catch him right I
don't think so you know sometimes you do
what you gotta do they stole that crane
too in the first place yeah so you slow
that to steal you can't really buy a
crane what's most bank robberies though
you're only getting like two three
thousand dollars you know that yeah
Google that hit our deal average bank
robber already laying over tight three
grand a 4-game here are denying story
when he was like 17 yeah
he goes this is gonna be funny with his
girlfriend he writes notice and the note
says I have a gun give me all your money
and the woman was like he was joking
around a woman gives him all this money
his like how far so they catch him
the they go to his house and the the
judge is like let's read this note I
have a gun a gun and you thought this
was funny anything [ __ ] or as I guess
sorry your honor he's this well you're
doing community service forever gave
them yeah that's not bad
17 yeah this day and age though you'd be
in trouble here it is
that was blank robbery netted about
$4,300 Wow
compared to an average of 1500 for all
commercial robberies
although and in green stores that
mistake is similar $60.00 got a lot of
bank robberies though look there you go
average bank robbery in England three
one thousand dollars I mean so you
didn't rob one yeah you pay the bills
man you have two key problem oh you
gotta keep robbing them do you think cuz
the movies you robbed you're set for
life right now you gotta keep doing it
keep doing you know hard as get away
with one yeah bank crime statistic yeah
man it's not I met her a real life bank
robber who through a mutual friend of
ours and he he was looking at a 35-year
bid
in Boston it's a famous case the
prosecutor or the DA or the scientist in
the forensics lab was fudging data and
they threw all the gazes away and he got
a second chance lock he was a career
bank robber
he's bank you know you know the town
that movie yeah one of those guys met
healthy met him spend time with him yeah
spent some time with him he and his
partner who did a lot of it very nice
guys just take some serious risks damn
look at that so number of like when it
goes to race so I mean there were some
females but 1200 at what year is this
2018 2018 12 hunt bases well basically
1,300 almost even 1,300 white guys 1,300
black guys oh it's all men I mean death
row is all men the violent criminals are
about 200 female yeah it's just it
they're usually brought in by the men
because they're dating them it's not
women it's like so funny when they
always talk about gender equality
okay how about death row let's see what
we can do about equating that men are
naturally more aggressive and violent
it's a physical thing it's not I've
never been a female serial killer act
there was actually more on I certainly
warn ya but overall you're right it's
it's a it's a male phenomenon oh yeah
and so know the sexes are not equal
noise and women nor would you want no
Asian women zero too polite yeah too
polite
I feel like Kat could rob a bank though
you're pretty gangster I mean well I
think what Asian people have is that
they stay under the radar like no one
really suspects them I used to joke
around with my friends all the time
because I could get prescriptions for
things because of my mental health and
just sell them to these rich kids who
are partying anyways and no one would
ever suspect me no I wouldn't the United
States say if you're embezzling money
from us you'd be the last
I think chin was the United States money
the United States last rose up big then
I know that the United States and Israel
that's the only two that I know do use
female assassins you're female you know
yeah people so if you go somewhere and
you need to not come out of
place I feel like it's a bad idea though
cuz I'd rather have chin as that well he
looks like an assassin but cat you'd be
drawn to right away you know but you
don't expect a woman to kill you so that
that hostage situation in Thailand blew
my mind I watched it over and over on oh
we've got or that bit yeah yeah and she
just shy don't know where I was like
where'd she come from but my babbling
just kills him the seven dailies female
assassins in history because this Asian
woman bottom right come on made that up
who are these happening oh yeah they're
all your kill Jonas Brothers or some
[ __ ] right that's a woman who did that
yeah who they just like tossed powder in
his faith they covered it in his face is
mouthing died hmm Oh Asian why he's all
agents Oakland alright a after she come
Ben was murdered by a Z well our Lord
okay this is hard not how you get the
fright this is [ __ ] who's this la
tigresa little sexual prowess so she's a
ho that one that one of the women in
basque independence just wants for obama
killed 12 civilian guards five more
seduced policemen before shooting
colleagues include killing most wanted
terrorists Wow seduced policeman before
shooting their colleagues and quickly
became one unless you're sentenced to
more than 1500 years in prison kicked
out the ETA pausing for actions right
this is just what what hmm yeah I don't
know
oh it's a guy that was killed by this
woman job Kim
that's a Korean 50 North mother a to
mass murder at age and I think she
hadn't been good from University keep
going North Korean agent change for six
years
Wow well there you go
well maybe they don't take down a South
Korean airliner placed a bomb in the
overhead compartments right before
disembarking the plane himself during a
stopover the bomb detonating all 150
onboard captured and confessed she said
area hats in 1989
but President wrote a will pardon her
she's now married to a former self in
intelligence Africa has two children
after defecting now lives in fear of
events from Pyongyang yeah you didn't
get away why'd you get pardon that's
[ __ ] crazy probably cuz she was
forced to do it or something huh maybe
they're not bored they just get old
mm-hmm
it'd just be crazy dude yeah man some
people will do it if you have a reason
do you have an ideology that you truly
believe in then cracking a couple of
eggs to make an omelet as they say isn't
ain't no big deal the film Anthon
everybody justifies the means justify
the end Isis all that stuff yeah as
opposed to the end doesn't justify the
means so kill kill in that logic goes
kill and people use it all the time and
still use it kill three thousand people
to save three hundred thousand people
tomorrow you do that math yeah it's a
hard math to get out of sometimes it's
exactly like the debate we had torture
torture works to an extent people say it
doesn't and if it works in getting
somebody to tell us where a bomb is to
save other lives the bigger question is
we know that we don't use torture it's
called cruel and unusual punishment now
will you how do you get around that how
do you get around that you know you just
got it is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]